这男的真的也不错了，
愿意承担你跟前面那个老公生的孩子的生活费，
愿意承担你的这个债务，
她还给你还了几万块钱的债务，
这男的真的挑不出来什么大毛病了啊，
我今年八六年呢，
也算十九四十了，
离婚了，
是带了两个孩子，
老大是跟着他爸那边的，
小的是跟着我，
现在是放在老家，
我妈妈在带，
我妈妈跟我弟媳妇儿帮我一起贷的，
我是在北京这边扣了个对象，
现在是什么情况呢？
刚认识那会儿，
她确实也挺好的，
我是负债，
帮我还了点万债，
后来一起决定做生意嘛，
反正就亏了挺多钱，
把他手里的钱亏完了以后，
还道欠了二三十个，
总共亏了多少钱啊，
有100来万吧，
那这个生意主意谁为主啊？
我觉得就是没有我的情况下，
他也不会做这个生意，
但是没有他，
我也不会说去弄这个事儿，
就不说了，
他当时还挺有担待的，
后来他把房子卖了以后，
就把这个钱还上了，
因为我俩在一起，
刚在一起那会儿，
他是给我还了个两三万外债，
那时候我自己有自己的工作，
也能养得起自己，
养得起孩子，
但现在的情况，
我们俩在一起，
他是搞运动培训的，
我就不上自己的班的，
一直就当他话说。
走的这种情况，
现在每个月孩子放在老家，
因为有时候让我弟媳妇儿啊，
跟我妈一起看着，
看人家心里不舒服，
一个月给2000，
我弟也是开店嘛，
做生意用我的信用卡亏了有3万多吧，
他现在没有能力还，
还不起，
我就怕逾期，
之前这个事儿没跟他说，
我自己强着头皮在还，
现在的情况就是我花的钱跟他说他都会给，
但是我手里是没有一分钱的，
之前包括我那信用卡的事儿，
我弟还不起，
我一直在还，
我说要，
要不然咱俩分手吧，
我说我天天手里没有一分钱，
我经济压力太大了，
他就同意一个月帮我还信用卡，
信用卡现在每个月是要还3000多的，
再加上孩子每个月2000块钱的生活费，
相当于工资吧，
还有一个月1500的奶粉钱，
我俩在一起的这两年多吧，
没有收到什么就像金戒指呀，
金项链这一类的礼物的，
他那种人是挺有上进心的，
但是他没有仪式感，
我俩吵架就是冷战，
他从来不会说哄你，
反正跟他在一起就相当于他一直在主导生活，
他说怎样就怎样的那种，
我现在好纠结要不要继续走下去，
按说一个月我这边的花销也有五六千嘛，
但是这些钱该花的确实都。
都花了，
他也有替我这边想，
今年的时候跟我说，
我爸妈年纪大了，
要买保险，
因为都是老人家，
在农村里也没有工作嘛，
身体也不好，
他俩人一年的保险是他提议给买的，
然后是一年三四千吧，
一个人应该是2000，
我觉得这些都挺好的，
唯一的点就是我每一天身上没有一毛钱，
我就跟他说我没钱了，
他会问我你干什么，
他会给这个钱，
但是我身上是从来存不住钱的，
你想问我什么问题吗？
我现在就觉得我要不要自己去找个工作，
如果我自己手里有钱了，
我可以为以后为我的孩子做打算什么的，
他是说明年等孩子大点，
把孩子接过来跟着我们，
我现在比如说想买个东西什么的都试试，
就得汇报的那种情况，
我觉得没有钱在手里，
特别没有安全感，
这男的真的是倒了血霉了找你，
这男的要来我直播间的话，
我劝他分手，
真是倒了血霉了，
找你，
如果不是因为找你也不会亏那套房吗？
也不会欠那100万吗？
是不是这个道理？
你刚才原话是不是说的，
如果没有你的话，
他不会做这买卖，
你原话不是那么说的吗？
当时这个是他一直要做这个生意的，
你主导，
不是，
我说一直我们的生活都是他在主导他。
提意要做，
我就是说不同意都不行的那一种，
只是说他认识我以后，
他可能就觉得这东西是不是会赚钱什么的，
他就想要做这个生意，
不是说我去让他做的，
是这个意思，
那我理解有问题，
我刚才听你说那话，
没有你的话他不做这生意，
因为他才做这个生意，
我理解是这个意思啊，
不是这我们家到现在也是他说了算，
他说让我做什么我就去做什么的这种，
我们家就是他比如说啊，
你去把这弄了，
把弄包装生活上的，
他人家也会说做饭回来做饭什么的，
但是洗碗呀，
打扫卫生呀，
这些肯定都是我干的，
我觉得我们俩在一起无所谓，
我唯一的一个点，
他确实哪都挺好，
也挺上进，
也不玩游戏，
顶多又钓个鱼，
包括你之前苦日子，
我们也都过来了，
现在的问题就打个比喻吧，
我们家我是自己有一套房子的，
如果他现在每个月在我身上的花销这些，
如果我俩不在一起，
我也有能力赚这个钱养孩子，
我是有这个能力的，
但是只是说当时就想着还是想找个人一起嘛，
包括我们家那房子阳台特别大，
一个有100多平的阳台，
要铺砖，
刚做好的防水，
它上面不是要铺砖，
或者是给他弄起来，
不然那防水都会晒坏嘛。
客户花这个钱，
他说行，
花到真正让花钱出这个钱的时候，
可能1万多吧，
后来就缩减成本，
我就想各种办法把这个钱省下来，
最后是3000块钱把这个阳台给搞定的。
我的意思就是我们之间现在他能挣钱，
他可能认知比我高，
我不是说钱非得放在我这里，
放在他那里他能挣钱没问题，
我的点就是我俩分手了，
我一个月能把养孩子这些钱赚回来，
但是我跟他在一起的话，
就是花所有的钱，
他现在心里有我这些钱他愿意花，
要是如果有一天没有我呢，
我是儿子呀，
我得为儿子以后娶媳妇什么的，
我俩要是结婚了，
这些钱他要是不愿意花，
我怎么办？
是这个意思。
你想问我的问题是什么呢？
就是想让您旁观者清，
觉得我们俩还有没有必要处下去，
我非常坦率的说啊，
这男的没有任何毛病，
男的既给你的孩子那头2000块钱，
还有奶粉钱1500块钱，
还有你弟弟亏钱了，
亏了你的信用卡，
每个月还3000块钱，
都是这男的在负担是吧？
我感觉这男的已经仁至义尽了，
对我也觉得是挺好的，
但是我自己心里想的有点多，
有时候就觉得，
我觉得是这样啊，
你要想挣钱没毛病啊，
你想挣钱你挣钱这样，
为什么你想挣钱就。
一定要分手了，
你才去挣钱呢，
因为他是体育培训机构的嘛，
那体育培训期间你可以跟他说啊，
你说我觉得我们两口子感情想要长久啊，
我不能总是依赖你，
我不能总是什么事都指着你，
我依赖你什么事儿总都指着你的话，
我自己自尊心也受不了，
所以呢，
我俩这日子照顾，
但是呢，
我自己去找一份工作，
我去挣钱，
把我弟弟的这个债啊解决掉，
把我自己孩子的生活费解决掉，
我俩在一起的话，
可能相对来说更轻松，
感情也更好，
你可以从这个角度聊嘛，
但是他不同意，
我说我出去自己上班，
他就说我这挺忙的，
又离不开的人，
他就属于那种特别粘人的，
包括现在我给怕他下手什么的，
所有考核去哪儿都是带着我一起的，
包括他忙的时候，
我就在车上等着，
他是这种状态啊，
那咱们就是公对公，
那就是说你找一个助理，
一个月发多少钱工资，
你有开多少钱工资，
咱把劳动合同一签，
或者说如果是合伙的话，
咱会把合伙协议一签，
咱不可能说黑不提白不提的，
因为你俩本身第一也没有结婚证是吧？
对，
因为结婚的这个事儿我跟他说过，
他说我想领证就随时去领，
我这就一直心定不下来嘛，
我就觉得是不是我想要的太多了呀，
龙辉姐，
我就说点实。
心的话啊，
咱们也是40多岁的人了，
一天天的穷，
讲究什么呢？
你们到底有什么资本一天天的讲究这仪式那仪式感的，
你们是被谁洗的脑？
一天天的讲究仪式感，
仪式感那个礼物的，
现在都还在生存边上挣扎，
都还没有个安身立命的所在，
都还在为以后的养老在挣扎，
苦苦生存，
还谈什么仪式感？
被谁洗的脑，
被哪个资本家洗的脑，
有什么资格谈仪式感？
我们现在40岁的女人，
要啥没啥对，
但是我从来没因为这个跟他生气，
我的意思就是说他该做的确实有，
也都做的特别好，
我心里这会儿就想着，
你说她也，
那我就跟你说实话，
要么咱们去吧，
亲兄弟，
您算账，
咱们就签个协议，
该给我开多少钱工资一个月开给我，
要么咱们就签合伙协议，
这样有一个保障，
要么我出去找工作，
咱俩的日子照过啊，
这男的真的也不错了，
愿意承担你跟前面那个老公生的孩子的生活费，
愿意承担你的这个债务，
他还给你还了几万块钱的债务，
这男的真的挑不出来什么大毛病了啊，
那听您这么说，
我这心就定下来，
一段一段儿的感觉，
你知道吧，
有时候问他要钱的时候，
他可能心情不好的时候，
他会觉得不愿意啊什么的，
换做是你，
如果你能挣钱，
如果钱是你挣的，
你谈到这个男朋友问你要钱。
想他跟前妻生的孩子，
问你要钱还他妹妹信用卡欠的债，
你心情好吗？
所以我就想着我自己能挣这个钱的话，
分手的话，
受这个委屈，
我什么就这么想，
人有的时候是这样换个角度想问题，
你也是在挣钱，
你挣这份钱，
你给的是情绪价值，
给的是陪伴，
你如果出去的话，
老板是不是也得坑儿你两句，
老板是不是也得对你不满意，
同事是不是还得排挤你，
都是在挣钱，
你就想想哪头挣钱对于你来说的话，
他都有牺牲，
他都有付出，
你看哪头合适，
行，
谢谢你，
那我就踏实了，
我就放下心来，
就想着领证好好过日子的事，
好，
嗯，
行，
好，
谢谢你啊，
那没有别的问题了，
我就觉得您见识挺多的，
请您分析一下，
我觉得这男的真的没毛病，
这男的没啥毛病啊，
嗯，
拜拜，
那没事儿了，
谢谢你。
嗯，
其实我说这话非常难听啊，
但是话糙理不糙，
都是在挣钱啊，
你上外头挣钱的话，
不也得受气吗？
也得老板坑你两句，
同事排挤你一下，
你俩给你穿个小鞋，
给你使点绊子，
在外面你还得朝九晚五的，
还得打卡，
还得公交车，
还得地铁，
还得堵车，
在外面风吹日晒的，
还得赶这个赶那个，
他哪头看哪头挣钱。
咱更什么一点啊，
记得点赞关注哦。